Steve I need your help to make my
serverless application more reliable and
ready for production
what reliability work have you done to
it so far nothing it's just a prototype
app and is not very reliable where
should I even start Steve
um well some simple smoke tests may be a
good first step they are easy to build
and easy to automate
can't wait to hear more
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Steve you told me the other day that you
have experience in reliability
engineering yeah I was a site
reliability engineer or SRE inside
Google for over a decade I worked on
search Android YouTube and Cloud now my
job is helping developers understand how
to build reliable systems on the cloud
perfect I have plenty of experience
writing apps but not really operating
them in a production environment and I
have a prototype app here that many of
my co-workers want to start using uh
what's the app
our team built an app for tracking
YouTube comments it's been exploratory
programming so far so we haven't written
any automated tests or anything like
that but people seem to like the
Prototype so we'd like to make it into a
real and reliable app
okay have you experienced any
reliability problems with the Prototype
yeah so we actually did a few months ago
YouTube changed a minor thing in their
API the app still kind of worked but it
was providing stale data for a month
before we noticed the problem got it uh
well you can make it more reliable by
adding a few smoke tests it's easy to do
so I recommend developers do it before
they spend their time on other more
expensive reliability work okay sounds
good why are smoke tests easy to add
well they're simple they don't test
everything the name comes from
electronic Hardware testing when you
would test a new circuit board you first
plug it in to the power if the board
starts to smoke you know the board is
bad and no further testing is required
ah right let's hope no smoke is coming
out of this app so so I wonder if I
already have a smoke test in my rest API
of this application so I have this
Handler here it returns an okay when you
send an http get to the URL slash test
yeah perfect we can use that as a smoke
test some people would call this a
simple health check when you send a
request to that URL and you get an okay
back you know that your code was
deployed and can receive requests if you
don't get an okay back no further
testing is required you can even set up
Cloud monitoring to hit that URL
periodically and alert you if it breaks
oh good idea let me do that now so let's
see first I'll scroll down to monitoring
and then I'll click uptime checks I
click create uptime check I'll give it
the title health check
uh then I'll pick https enter the host
of my cloudron service I'll enter test
as that's the path of my health check
I'll let it run every minute that's the
default the response should contain the
string o k my health check should return
a response with the status code 200 and
everything is okay so leave all these
defaults in place
next I'll tell it to alert me I don't
have any alert channels set up yet so
I'll create one here
I'll set it alert me by email
now I can go back and refresh the
notification channels
ah there's my new email alerting Channel
I'll pick that one
done
now it will send me an email if the
slash test URL or my cloud run service
returns a bad status code or if the
status
response doesn't contain the string okay
so this will test that you haven't had a
bad deployment or like if the container
keeps crashing but you could do more
like you said before that your app uses
the YouTube API yeah that's the part
that broke a few months ago at this
simple okay test would not have caught
that huh right so now you can copy your
simple health check into a new deep
health check which exercises the major
part of your application maybe your code
could hit the YouTube API yeah let me
add that uh it will call the YouTube API
I will ask the API for all videos in
this particular playlist
and here I'll check that I got more than
zero results back and this method
started throwing exception before if it
does that again it will be caught here
and a 500 error will be returned
you probably have other system
components as well you could exercise
them too yep yep I do have a database uh
should I add a code for that here in
this health check actually it's useful
to put the different smoke tests behind
different endpoints that way if there is
a failure you'll know right away which
system component caused it ah makes
sense uh let me add an endpoint for the
database smoke test
my code could ask which videos so
certain user subscribes to I'll add the
code here
oh oh but Steve wait a minute uh I don't
know which users have added which videos
in the application and this could even
change over time how would this smoke
test code know if the returned data is
correct good question remember this is
only a smoke test and it's not a full
integration test we'll talk about those
more in a future episode but at this
point we're simply plugging in the power
and checking to see if smoke is coming
out or not so you could call the
database and just make sure that no
exception is thrown ah I see what you
mean uh just check no smoke is coming
out okay I will tweak my code so it asks
for user one two three and that user
probably doesn't exist uh but the code
should be able to connect to the
database anyway and run the query and
return an empty result and if the code
can't connect to the database and
exception will be thrown and this
endpoint will return a 500 error great
so now once you have one endpoint per
major system component you can monitor
them as well with Cloud monitoring or
another tool of your choice
right I will add these new tests to
Cloud monitoring it was really easy to
write this mock tests Steve that's right
um it's it's easy to set up smoke tests
on serverless platforms like Cloud run
if you use Virtual machines or
kubernetes you have to make sure that
you test every machine in your cluster
with serverless Google hides that
complexity got it uh so I guess none of
my smoke tests so far check the
JavaScript front end of my my app yeah
that that's another way you could
improve your smoke tests you could set
up some basic regular expression
matching to ensure that the page content
is what you expected for example let's
make sure that the footer shows up and
therefore we can pretty much expect the
whole page was loaded we're not checking
any content from the database just the
content from the front end itself we
want your smoke test to be very limited
in scope uh okay it sounds like it could
be a lot of work to set all these up
yeah as you get more and more tests and
your tests become more complex you may
eventually want some more tooling many
companies build their own tools to
organize and run many health checks on
their systems and there are also third
parties that provide such tools and
there's an open source software for this
too there's one called cloud prober
ah I got it that's a lot to think about
um so what would be the next baby step
to make my app more reliable well you
already have basic smoke tests you could
run them continuously via Cloud
monitoring when running these type of
tests in production sometimes they're
called probes or Black Box monitors
sometimes you'll see them called
synthetic monitoring also the goal is to
have them run often enough to catch a
real failure in your system quickly so
now you have set up automated smoke
testing you only spent a few minutes on
this and your app is already in a much
better place than it was before down the
line you could even add this to your CI
CD process to ensure that the system is
working before you expose new code to
your users sounds good Steve and thank
you everyone for watching spend a few
minutes and add some smoke tests to your
app if you have any questions or topic
suggestions for future episodes please
add them in the comments until next time
[Music]
thank you